around 1585 to the nearest tens let me  rewrite the number 1585 to the nearest  10 so we want to focus on the tens place  we want to focus on the tens place if we  were to round it up if we were to round  it up we would go to 1,500 let me let me  color code it we would round up to 1590  the eight would round up to a nine and  ninety if we were to round down we would  go to one thousand five hundred and we  would round down to eighty so these are  our two choices now we've seen the last  two examples if the place to the right  of it is five or greater if it is 5 or  greater we round up well the place to  the right of it is definitely five or  greater it is 5 so we round up so it is  1590 and we're done